now I have a look at Part C and this is
where your arm is to make the polymer
and your stuff starts to come in see
show the sum of those six roots okay is
equal to and then they give you this all
this random stuff okay so what's going
on let's get some um let's get some
results down and see if we can
understand what they want us to show it
is because I've named them in such a way
there's some of these six roots z1 plus
in fact I will do better than that
because I'm adding up a whole bunch of
things that go in sequence I have
notation that will do this for me that
will add up in the first one up to the
whichever one I want in this case the
sixth one I'm going to say the sum from
N equals one to six of all of my actual
roots Zn I want to show that that is
equal to that let's just write it down
because actually having it there is
gonna useful first so work out where the
where the bits I'm gonna need okay so
I've got two and then I have these
guides
okay now before I just jump in and tell
you how on earth do we get this result
okay you stay very carefully at this
result that we're trying to prove okay
in fact we're going to do this a couple
of other times like that when they give
you an on top they've really trying to
help you they really want you to get
there okay so this is supposed to help
us it's supposed to help us
j pi 9 4 pi 9 8 pi 9
okay whether these angles are Piaf in
our diagram those are those angles are
the arguments of the three roots that
I've identified right this one said one
that makes you plan 9 the first one this
one for pi 9 is the second one
chu pi and I am 4 pi 9 I skip 1 6 5 9
why do I skip it's a solution of the
other guy right because 6 pi 9 is 2 pi
and 3 which is 1 of the cube roots of
unity ok so I skip six pile of 9 and
then I come all the way around to a
prime of nine okay so there are those
results that's the first thing I notice
secondly I only get cosines why I only
got cosines because each of these
numbers has a cosine of real part and a
sign an imaginary part why are the
imaginary parts appear ok now when I add
them all up and this is the point of me
saying this is not just a fourth root
it's the conjugate of the first one and
this is not just the fifth root it's the
conjugate of the second one etc the
reason why I highlighted that is with
you and say these guys not the imaginary
parts will cancel and when you add these
the imagine a classroom cancel and
cancel okay so all the signs should
disappear
is that right so how do I demonstrate
this I can't really easily I'm gonna say
this is what I'm required to prove right
so this this is the way that I would set
it up is equal to its just z1 z2 z3 at
4:00 to 5:30 6:00 but these are 45 cent
sixes are actually conjugates so I'm
going to include that
my work said 1 plus Z 2 plus Z 3 plus
now my conjugates come in ok
Claude you get it 1 ok remembering that
this is a show question ok I need to
really demonstrate that I know what's
going on so I want you to pair up my
conjugates and make it super obvious
that I see the connection so there's the
first one in its conjugate there's the
second one
and it's conjugates and there's the
third one its conjugate okay now the
purpose of me writing this next step or
that step that I just wrote it's so that
like I can write every single one of
these in cosmos I sign for I can do it
and everything will cancel but it would
take me forever ok so having paired that
up that is my mechanism by which I think
it's justified to say when you add a
complex number to its conjugate the
imaginary parts cancel and the real
parts double so I'm going to write it
like this 2 times the real part I'll
take one you see that like if I paid him
up I think that makes that that just
advise this next step ok plus 2 times
the real part is it 2 plus 2 times the
real part
ok so this is 2 outside of first one is
2 by 9 and the last one is a Python done
ok you happy with that that is the sum
all the roots okay now you just have to
have a look at this next one there are
two issues right that's firstly this was
what I'm up to
I'm not too deep so that was a and B was
the drawing and this was C for Part D
what I'm required to prove is this
result which is almost it's almost this
result isn't it but it's not quite this
is what they want they want to close
super
Plus cause for fire 9 plus sorry equals
cause fine okay so I pause and look at
this and I say especially because it
says hence I say what connection do I
see between this guy and this guy right
hmm the first thing I noticed which sort
of sticks out like a sore thumb is that
a pile of mine has disappeared where'd
it go
it has swapped like 2009 they match up
for pi night
they match up and then suddenly is 8 pi
o 9 it has done two things number one
it's somehow I've gotten onto the other
side of the equation and secondly it's
turned into a different angle together
okay so let's just try and tease this
apart here first because you just need
to learn how can I get from one to the
other right